وماثيو، أعلم أنك في سانت
بطرسبرغ الليلة حيث ألقى بوتين أيضًا نظرة
على المشكلات القانونية التي يواجهها دونالد ترامب،
وكان من
المثير للاهتمام حقًا ما قاله، كان لديه
الكثير ليقوله،
وأقصد بالفعل بشكل منفصل تلك
القضية الكورية الشمالية، أه الرئيس بوتين
كان يدفع بدعمه مرة أخرى
للرئيس السابق أه دونالد ترامب إنه
شيء تتذكره أصبح سمة
من سمات الحملة الانتخابية لعام 2016 في
رئاسة ترامب اللاحقة حسنًا الآن
يضعها مرة أخرى هذه المرة قائلاً إن
التهم الموجهة ضد دونالد ترامب لها
دوافع سياسية ولكن أيضًا  إن الاستمتاع
بالانقسامات التي تسببت بها تلك القضايا
في الولايات المتحدة
فيما يتعلق بمحاكمة ترامب،
فهذا أمر جيد بالنسبة لنا في
ظروف اليوم لأنه يظهر
تعفن النظام الأمريكي الذي
لا يستطيع التظاهر بتعليم الآخرين عن
الديمقراطية كل ما يحدث.  مع
ترامب هو اضطهاد
منافس سياسي لأسباب سياسية ويتم ذلك
أمام جمهور
الولايات المتحدة والعالم كله [
موسيقى]
ERS للنظام الأمريكي أه الرئيس
بوتين يميل إلى محاولة صرف الانتباه عن
المشاكل  وتحدث بوتين عن روسيا من خلال الإشارة إلى
القضايا الجارية في بلدان أخرى
وخاصة الولايات المتحدة فيما
يتعلق باحتمالات
تغيير السياسة إذا كان هناك فوز ورقة رابحة،
وقال بوتين إنه لا يرى أي تغيير في
السياسة بغض النظر عمن سيفوز بالرئاسة الأمريكية
بفارق كبير.  روسيا تعيش الليلة
ودعنا نتجاوز الأرقام مع هاري
أنطون لذا هاري أنت تعلم أنك سمعت
ماثيو يتحدث عن
المؤتمر الصحفي لبوتين نعم تعلم أن بوتين اغتنم
فرصًا متعددة اليوم للحديث
عن النظام السياسي الأمريكي
أم إثارة القدر على دونالد ترامب أه
فأين الجمهور الأمريكي
الآن عندما يتعلق الأمر بروسيا والحرب
في أوكرانيا، نعم أعني أنه
لا يوجد أحد على جانبي
الممر السياسي، وعدد قليل جدًا من الأشخاص على
جانبي الممر السياسي من
المعجبين بـ  الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ولكن الشيء الوحيد الذي
تطور حقًا خلال العام
ونصف العام الماضيين هو وجهات النظر عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالزعيم الأوكراني الرئيس زيلينسكي وما نراه هناك
انقسام حزبي مستقطب هائل، كما تعلمون، هذه هي
وجهات النظر غير المواتية لـ  الرئيس زيلينسكي
ونرى أن الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريين في عام 2022 عدد قليل جدًا من
أي منهما كان لديه آراء سلبية
عن زيلينسكي ولكن انظر إلى الجمهوريين الآن،
41 منهم لديهم آراء سلبية عن
زيلينسكي مقابل 11 فقط من الديمقراطيين، لذا
يبدو أن هذا الإسفين الحزبي  من
المؤكد أنها وجدت طريقها إلى
اللغة الروسية، وهذا أمر لا يصدق على الإطلاق
عندما تفكر في الأمر، فأنت تعرف كيف
يمكن للتصور أن يغير السياسة
شيئًا ما كان لدى الناس مثل هذا
الإيمان العاطفي به ويمكن أن
يتغير